[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
we are in Japan yes we are in Kyoto this
is our very tiny room look to that
Isaac's bed that's so funny
so we put like this couch together and
then this chair was it comfy for me
yeah I'm pretty comfy yeah cuz I told
you I'm like listen if you are not
comfortable there we can just somehow
figure out how to fit all three of us in
this bed it looks like a decent size but
we'll see you lay down it gets really
small but anyway we're here and Kyoto
and we're about to go have our very
first breakfast we landed last night it
was a very long flight oh that right I
get excited when I run things by
accident but like lose your tooth baby
Isaac got his wires change right before
coming and then look up look at how
crazy this is they left it sticking out
like crazy cuz they gotta do some
extreme movements before teeth get nice
and straight close your mouth and then
like he could see it so weird and also I
would like to point out that this is the
first time we've ever packed this light
we only brought that and that for all
three of us we didn't even bring a
carry-on either after all the trust
you've taken all these years finally and
this is also a two-week trip because
right after we're going to Korea so I'm
actually very proud of us we made
everything fit in these two breakfast
time
according to what you get baby good and
then would you get I just tried the miso
soup is so yummy there's a cute little
River this is so tranquil I love Japan
it feels like we're in a movie set every
time man just think with my braces are
annoying me a lot sorry
it's part of the process hi guys along
you know what's cool about Japanese and
Chinese you can read it the kanji is
interchangeable yeah I know what the
safeassign stock page help which means
that South black rich ha way it's
written I can read it in Spanish and in
English
yeah it's phonetic yeah try to be a
school thank you so funny
[Music]
cutie pie this is your first
international overseas trip whose jet
like nah I know me too I'm like talking
with my eyes like half open yeah we're
like drunk I think are you yeah you are
you woke up at 5:00 a.m. that's been
jetlag that's pretty dead like dude you
don't wake up like that I know I
actually you really wake up you usually
wake up at 5:00 and yeah right you try
to be cool I can always count on you
jumping over these poles every time we
travel
[Music]
all right so we're killing some time
with Barton geo and TECA and we came
across this temple so we're gonna go
check it out oh by the way they're doing
a wishing well thing I finally have a
camp a real camera in my hand after like
five years of taking a break from
Annabelle Cameron so all the view role
is because of this camera thank you
David borrow it would you do baby
purify yourself I don't think you're
supposed to do that yeah this is one of
the first times in a long time I've
actually brought a real camera onto a
vacation for a vlog we're actually out
here in Japan doing a video piece for
sip Mancha which is the reason why I
borrowed David's cam this is actually
David's camera to make a more cinematic
experience for this video it's also
forced me to relearn how to use a camera
I'm actually really rusty I feel I get
rid of this rust right now I think my
scimitar B skills have diminished quite
a bit over the three years of vlogging
with automatic cameras I'll see how it
goes
look there's fishy would you say I'm
gonna sleep with the vision alright so
we just got back to the hotel room and I
saw this I was like oh my god there's a
pink rose and it says happy Mother's Day
tip and then I was hugging you I was
like thank you guys and then what did we
find out didn't even do that I think was
trying to get away with it though he was
like yeah yeah yeah Wow I forgot to show
it to you thank you I mean I appreciate
the thought but I thought this was from
you guys you know I think we're making
eye contact it it felt like I think was
looking at me like Daddy was that you is
this you
and I'm like no but then I was like oh
thank you thank you guys thank you and
then I was like giving kissing a kiss
and then I just saw them making eye
contact I'm like did you guys get Street
they're like no I think it's the hotel
so here I'll open it find out who really
was thoughtful
Oh it was June dan Anna Jeremy and karma
Lisa Dan you guys this happy Mother's
Day tip we are so happy you are spending
your special day with us your hard work
unconditional love and dedication to
Isaac should be celebrated today and
every day always thank you guys
oh great they gave me a little fan oh my
god that is so sweet
I gotta give them a big hug and say
thank you so much that is so sweet
and I love how you guys are trying to
take the credit technically mother's
days worthless because every day is my
whoa whoa okay good okay is Mother's Day
and we should respect our mothers every
day instead of just one day with you
okay okay Mother's Day
thank you thank you today oh crap it
actually is today first and then the day
we laugh was Mexican Mother's Day and
anything we get a Mother's Day that I
was very sick with you this morning
though oh no the energy was there it's
just the realization of the actual day
it was not yeah okay Isaac's right every
day is Mother's Day right all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we all got together at the donut shop
here
which and planets all together and then
mama can be heard hi mama
yeah you guys made it happy Mother's Day
or you guys check up on his birthday
so that's funny yeah yeah we're all here
everyone together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
we're in a texting now we are headed to
the temple 23 I think every time we come
to Japan we're old too deep like Japan's
not the country to come with a big group
of people but every time we come we have
like at least 20 people in our group but
yeah we're heading there now
I'm actually excited to go to this place
because the last time we were here again
we split up in different groups because
it's just too crazy for us to all be
together and we like one part of the
group ended up going to the nari temple
I don't know what we did instead but we
didn't end up going and I was really
bummed out and I was looking at the
photos of the people that did go up like
oh lucky it looks so pretty and then now
we get to go this time
love that no idea what we're doing
I was tired so the group that have
babies
so part Gio and Christina they ended up
going back to the hotel to rest up and
just let the babies rest and then Isaac
can't tell them about your song he was
like making up this little song and he
was pretty much was saying like can you
have a baby next time but I forgot the
melody like the rhythm of how it went
but anyway he was saying that and I was
like oh how cute this is new song he's
like yeah I will take care of him or her
can you have a baby next time so I was
like that's so sweet and then I end up
finding out that the reason why he said
he wants us to have a baby so then he
could be going to the hotel with the
baby crew so I'm like ah it was for
selfish reasons actually now I said that
and two reasons Oh what was the other
one because I was playing with taken and
I'm like
shoveling so you really do want to
believe yeah that's so sweet baby yeah
you've really taken to take on this trip
and take it has taken to you on this
trip a lot to which you guys haven't
really bonded before until this trip
that's really cool to see you guys like
do stuff together I know I mean it's so
cute out it take it just wants to keep
hugging you and then everything that
Isaac does he just copies it it's so
freakin cute yesterday there's a moment
where I were at the airport and I think
lays on the floor yeah cute and then
earlier today too I I forgot what Isaac
did but he ended up like smacking his
own face as as a way of saying like oh I
messed up and then take a mmediately
copy that that's freaking cute I'm like
see that's practice that you need to be
a good role model because kids copy
everything you do but yeah I forgot to
mention the whole reason why we came to
Japan is for sit
so sip matcha is this place that the
drink place and so much and stuff and so
Casey and I we recently became partners
in the company so pretty much everyone
that's on this trip - Casey's parents
our partners and sip and the reason why
we came out here is so we can get to see
the actual matcha farm where we source
the matcha - that we use for sip and
it's like high quality stuff we're gonna
actually visit the farm and see because
this is the season where they're picking
the baby leaves which I believe are like
the highest quality grade of matcha you
can get but we decided to just make it
like an entire company bonding trip kind
of thing and so we stopped in kyoto
first and then
just spend time with everybody and
really just bond with everyone Anna
Jeremy Jun and Dan those are the four
main people that started this company
and so like they're the ones that are
taking care of us for this trip so it's
really nice and we don't get to spend
that much time with them so this trip is
really cool we get to really bond with
everybody we're here look at that I
think you remember the last time we were
in Kyoto we saw this but we didn't get
to go all the way inside do you remember
that are you forgot I remember seeing
this we just didn't good to go all the
way inside let's go see we could find a
can clan yeah you blend there with your
orange shirt all right so we've been
hiking mount Inari for over an hour I
think it's like an hour and a half now
we finally made it to the top of the
summit and I think wanted to explore all
these shrines interesting yeah it's like
a tight squeeze in here whoa this is
cool
so tranquil you hear the birds cut for
the mountain - yeah you know top of the
morning
top of the mountain
[Music]
and right so now we're on a mission to
find wag you so Isaac went with the rest
of the group to go eat some gyoza and
that restaurant looks so good but we
wanted to save our appetite to eat with
the Chan clan and to have some Wagyu
beef because last time we were in Kyoto
I think got to enjoy some really
delicious Wagyu beef and Katie and I
somehow managed to split and we ended up
eating at the mall with some spaghetti
it was like our biggest regret from that
trip so now we're like all right I think
we gotta go eat some beef but he wanted
the gyoza right so he stayed back in the
hotel to go to sleep she was very tired
it is pretty late oh yeah we're on this
really famous at Ali called funkdoc Cho
le which I'm probably butchering but
this alley is so cute it's like so tiny
because it's an alley obviously and
there are so many restaurants and
everywhere we're passing by we're like
whoo
that smells good and that smells good
but we're like no we're on a mission we
got to find swagoo beat all right we
finally found a good place we got all
these different slices of meat that is
the wagon
first things first a butter the grease
this is a new clutter
how many healthier dividers yeah what's
that something they're all like you
[Music]
mom that's really good it's like butter
oh that's so good
just what we needed after a long day of
hiking forever
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]